l'ouverture cette semaine du grand
marathon des collections de haute
couture 22 couturier vont jusqu'à jeudi
présenté à la presse et aux acheteurs
près de 2000 robe ce qui nous amène à la
coquette somme de deux milliards et demi
de centimes france roche retour en force
du tailleur chez jean patou le modèle
haute couture qu'on porte une jupe
culotte très travaillé la doublure du
manteau étant sur 1,12 cent tandis que
dans le modèle prêt à porter la jupe
culotte est plus simple mais de mantoue
comporte les mêmes des coûts la doublure
est plus normal chez perse boucle les
rayures lardeau couture et très ample
tandis que la robe de prêt à porter
et plus étroite
chez lanvin les contrastes le manteau
trois-quarts le bustier
et ne venez autour du père
pour le prêt à porter ou nous jettent
auront encore le manteau trois-quarts
celui des haute couture est entièrement
fendue dans le dos le manteau prêt à
porter à un petit harvey pour lui tout
seul
chez cardin la symétrie les épaules
carrées le modèle en lainage effet dans
un ménage très cher qu'avec le modèle en
imprimé dans un tissu plus simple le col
est moins élaborés
chez gibert ferruch les angles
géométriques et des pointes la robe de
haute couture un décolleté très trompe
l'oeil
l'ensemble prêt à porter à dmanche plus
simple chez carven la petite robe
imprimé fleuri
la robe de haute couture à un travail de
liserés aux manches un volant tandis que
l'as rome de prêt à porter et taillé en
économisant un peu plus de tissus et les
petites fleurs sont toujours de rigueur
chez nina ricci les gans les jeux de
rayures l'opposition noir et blanc en
haute couture un costume avec lequel on
ne peut pas aller au marché
en prêt à porter
et
oui
le taillan d'après-midi d'elle la paille
sera marqué j'ai l'habitude par exemple
dans la robe de haute couture en jersey
de soie
elles exploitent et de pierreries plus à
la main tandis qu'en prêt à porter il
m'a pas bien mais la robe est courte
elle est en jeu est claire ou alors il
n'y aura pas de taille chez ferro de
robes de mousseline la haute couture est
entièrement permet à la main mais le
prêt à porter a droit à la même fleurs
imprimées et si vous ne pouvez pas payer
ni la haute couture et le prêt-à-porter
offre une voilette